there we are buddy there we are it's
Wednesday no it's Thursday it's Thursday
[ __ ] it's Thursday but it's it feels
like Wednesday
the days are long how was your Halloween
oh it was nice yeah the day seems super
long so we could put 5:00 every morning
yeah every more anybody's week like now
it's it's like you know what is it the
next week I don't know yeah I don't know
Oh Bry who has the energy of six men
here's what you don't want to do with me
you don't want to give me eight hours of
sleep and give me two cups of coffee
because I'm ready to fight and run a
marathon at the same time that's a good
thing dude it's a very good thing well
you guys have erectile dysfunction yeah
I'll show you right now dude I've seen
it with my own eyes thank you now so I
got that going for me the thing is
what's new for me is when ten o'clock
rolls around cuz daddy's getting up
early at 6:00 and stuff 10 o'clock rolls
around ready for bed yeah Papa needs a
nap around 4:00 p.m. I shut it down kind
of doesn't happen sometimes for my son
goes no not on my watch yeah and then
I'm usually if I'm not doing sets late
at night
I'm bed at 9:00 sir well couples leave
by 9:30 a couple things that daddy's
been doing secretly you don't know about
number one [ __ ] dudes I called it
okay I knew it nope that's that's
something that I want to talk about
that's something that when I was in
college I went through a phase now let's
you'll want to leave private
oh I'll leave that private won't come
out but I'll shut it down as you know
I'll take myself a 20 minute no longer a
20 minute nap will shut it down power
yeah and there's an app called waking up
by Sam Harris
it's about meditation it's guided
meditation I may or may not have been
doing that for the past 45 days and if I
seem unusually centered if I seem like
I'm copacetic in general and have deep
understanding if my eyes cause a
soothing sort of Aurora aura and Aurora
it's not a word you're from what will
Rory is yeah I'm from there but if I
have a soothing aura about me that's
contagious it's cuz I've seen the other
side brother do I'm glad you said this
you've seen the other side I have is it
the other side of boring because there
have been really boring Brandon do you
meditate and just makes you born Brandon
I am dealing with I'm dealing with
consciousness or
a more conscious are you Russell Brand's
here's the problem with [ __ ] Russell
Brand's post jeez God had to stop
falling them other things that kind of
dude
yeah he's the real honey come lately to
all this new [ __ ]
Joseph Campbell was I read and [ __ ] in
college and the guy's spewing about it
I'm like hey bro you know it's like
Madonna when she came out Madonna came
out after like she'd been famous is
[ __ ] for 30 years or whatever and she
goes she goes you know what in the end I
realized that it's all about loving
other people too late hey man thanks for
what I learned in high school it's too
late
Eileen I like Russell Brand I'm a huge
fan of him I think he's hilarious love
his movies he's one of the best guests
on Rogen by far it's a lot to take in
though yeah he's sober now but in this
direction he's going and God bless him
like click on surviving a breakup let's
see what happens there he is a badass
cousin we broke up with Katy Perry he's
you know when they got the divorce he
was owed to half for [ __ ] his no I
don't want that I didn't earn that
that's not fair for him yeah so when
they took 20 million god bless them I
like Katy Perry just kidding he's a
handsome son of a [ __ ] yeah breakups
always do here's my advice to you on how
to survive a breakup one except that the
break-up is the right thing and that
it's happened to accept that you can
control nobody except yourself 3 realize
that you cannot invest your well-being
in the perception of another person or
learn to let go and move on 5 crust that
the future is gonna be ok for you but
not only are you gonna find someone
who's reading a hormone Kriya because
that in a sense is a repetition of the
pattern that you're trying to break but
that you will find in this world
everything you need if you are willing
to let go of other people's approval as
the primary source I go to nutrition and
instead he does drop some knowledge like
there's some gems and some of stuff but
it's it's everyday
yeah I I always I'm always wary of what
else is yeah bones self-professed
messiahs yeah lease he's done something
I I hate the guys who are just
motivational for like their success is
being motivational speakers
betta have done nothing prior they're
just motivational guys yeah he's a sexy
son of a [ __ ] though he's smart due to
he's he's a yeah
very well-read speaks [ __ ] intelligent
he's he's a he's a former addict who
like a lot of addicts has had a rebirth
and sort of a he's kind of like born
again in a way right at the wrong with
Doug no but it does create a bit of a
it's almost like he's saying this to
himself you know yeah you're gonna keep
himself together
keep going - have I ever said to you
Brennan in life you know no dealing with
jealousy click on that this one might be
good he does drop some germs know the
jealousy ones in the video yeah yeah
this isn't original though the system
will see and envy are both energies
correct if you can interpret them
correctly are encouraging you to change
or to endeavor
so I'm jealous I mean all they're doing
well look at them they're really famous
that means oh I'm feeling inadequate in
myself like I should be more that I'm
not good enough
also I'm judging other people's outsides
by my insight I don't know what other
people feel like but if I'm to glean
anything useful from jealousy what I
must think is what is it that I'm not
doing that I could be doing that what am
i doing he's right though I know I stuff
this right so I'm but I take again it's
all procrastination I also excuse me as
long as helping people hopefully it's
helping young people I guess but do
stand up because you're really good at
comedy do comedy and acting that's what
he's really good at
honestly like I like he doesn't want to
be like guys like Jim carrion and he
step out of that for a while and it's a
form of a crisis I look at it as it as a
low-grade nervous breakdown really I
don't I think maybe they climbed that
mountain with like Dom good man and
moved on it's a nerve it's still a
nervous breakdown where they climbed
that mountain right so what drives them
is something maybe unhealthy so what
drives them to get to the top is
something then they realize they have to
confront that and then they come back
down they go just so you guys know it's
not all about this I know that we all
Herren t know that I I still think he
would have more effect and more change
in doing what he's kind of really good
at naturally they define a battle does
it like doing that well so when you say
doing that what I would what I would say
is he's doing exactly the same thing so
acting comedy is
just a form of original self-expression
if you do it right and when you're being
original with your self-expression as
opposed to this I think you're gonna
find all the answers you don't think
he's been aroused dammit you're trying
not really meditate a little too hard no
no I don't enjoy this I think again it's
a form of his way of coping it's just
another form of coping I think that what
I'm saying is that for me I don't think
it's original I don't think they're as
original at all I'm too old I've seen
this said maybe 1,000 times I think um
but I like him and I think he's
penetrating and I think he's
entertaining again I wish he would do
what got him there in the first place
and find wolf and I think he could find
fulfillment in that because he could
continue to be original in that which he
was only he would know you know yeah
like maybe he's like dude I don't feel
like being on the road yeah it's his
journey he's doing he's doing he like a
lot of us is doing the best he can
I like Russell Brand he's doing what he
wants yeah I've always liked his huge I
don't I only met him once it has nothing
to do with that I've always liked him
like if he was in a movie I would want
to see it if he was doing stand-up I
wanted to see all of them every movies
yeah I just need to I've always been
drawn to yeah eminently watchable I
think he just look he's you know what he
is he's the rich man's Chris D'Elia
that's what he is he's a British Chris
D'Elia by the way if he queasily well
Greg Chris Billy thank you sir if he
walks into a room correct me if I'm
wrong and we love Chris if he and Chris
walk into a room all eyes all eyes on
the morrow bread and they go who's your
who's your what's the word you use for
my shoes or the other day who's your um
your beat your beat your be younger
brother are you saying Chris D'Elia is
an alley cat version of Chris Lee is the
bus and truck version of Russell Brand
Chris D'Elia is the junior varsity that
is Russell Brand's d1 athlete am I wrong
I love crystal HP right he's a beautiful
man but don't kid you when he walks in
the room Chris D'Elia gets down on one
knee goes me Lord you damn right and by
the way when Chris Lea walks in with any
girl on the planet oh she goes hold my
beer Chris he sucked him off he comes in
he's taking I'm taking you up it's got a
little really high voice I'm taking your
girl I'm taking you go to Napa Valley do
you mind doesn't matter and she and he
goes oh yeah and she goes by Chris yeah
every time yeah I agree
right yeah he's another level yeah you
know so so powerful beard - yeah that's
right Chris can Chris and wonderful
she's around him and when Chris is
around him tastes something else happens
to Chris he starts talking like this a
bit he's not it's not even aware of it
but he's talking about Chris stressed
okay so it doesn't there's no he's doing
he's like no I'm not really I mean no
I'm not really [ __ ] he's influenced by
him how did we estar us Alberto I'm
around Russell Brand I'm probably bad as
we go down this path I don't know but I
like it sometimes guys have an
enlightenment they [ __ ] so many girls
against climbing the mountain like you
he was he talks about in Rogen he was a
sex addict but John Mayer was the same
way too he can't with some minute reset
he's [ __ ] north of 2000 girls some
like that why he would tell anyone that
I have no idea but probably help the
other guys realize that having sex with
all the girls isn't all it's cracked up
to be
yeah okay so all the girls yeah I'd say
it is but I mean you know yeah but I
forget what he really if you look it up
Jim that'd be great but he died he came
it's a recent interview said no I won't
say north of I forget I think Russell
Brand is a genuinely good person though
like he's gee I would be his best friend
right now I refuse like a you're gonna
Brahma he's my friend like Brian you get
a text says see you that's a guy to get
on the podcast sounds the famous man
1000 no that's Russell Brand I'm talking
about John Mayer said recently these are
all the women he's had he's been with
people that are famous that I've slept
with a lot of people know it should pop
up
Jan if you type in John Mayer mmm it
should be just in the news gets recent
reports 500 come on John hey John I mean
I'm come on bro yeah hey come on bro
you don't write your bodies of wonder
let it not [ __ ] a fascist Hey brennick
oh you you played John Mayer and I'm
asking how many people you had sex with
them and then you give me your answer
and then I'll show you my reaction
John huge fan man love you bro um you
bet you you've bed some women down would
you do you have a number for me
pre writing your body's Wonderland or
after I don't know man and maybe total
just off the top my head yeah oh hey
don't wanna know I'm sure I'm gonna
breath oh let me grab gonna grab my seat
cuz I know I mad about that no I'm about
to freak out this is gonna be exciting I
mean white-knuckle here how many did
Wilt Chamberlain do well they saved
north of 10,000 he was a beast I did
five hundred give or take hey Brendan
John said he had sex with five hundred
he thinks that's a lot I feel like I
feel like John's just lying here I think
it's got to be more than slept more than
five hundred but it says more than five
hundred people so now I have heard
around the the Hollywood had a cooler
that he was eventually like dude I
[ __ ] every hot girl in the book why
not try out dudes really I don't know
about the happening on the guitar and
got his dick sucked I've never had that
impulse I've never like when I was a
young man I put up some numbers and I
never once was like you know what a lot
of girls this past two weeks I needed
Dom yeah maybe you're if you're John
Mayer though you know you're like God
your body is a wonderland you're like
playing the guitar like dude three hos
around here
hey bro seen him a couple times in
person may have the biggest head I've
ever seen in my life never seen a head
sawed Conan O'Brien wants the two of
them had on O'Brien oh hey doma that
could fit you could fiddle how John
Mayer jump on stage and do some stand-up
with Dave Chappelle which is kind of
weird yeah he's a VC he's friends with
David off Hilary he'll do some stand-up
with him John Mayer oh yeah counted dude
yeah he's a guy who made it was said I'm
what's that he kind of made all that
music man I'm good
did he he just does [ __ ] now like
he's not
there's no album steaming last John
Mayer single you heard hope pop up every
now and just like he was on satellite
live just [ __ ] riffing on the guitar
while like lil Uzi was performers some
[ __ ] but well came the last thing he's
done Cat Stevens at the height of his
power Cat Stevens at the height and one
of the greats
one of the great folk singers of all
time never nah you never have nope as
big as it gets
in the 70s honestly in the 70s as big as
it gets cues me know he was he was an
international superstar for real in the
70s and he went swimming and he almost
drowned and he said if I make it back
I'm gonna dedicate my life to God and he
kind of saw God out in the water I guess
and came back and then became a
essentially a Muslim cleric it started
with Christianity didn't work became
Muslim and then came back recently so
John just kind of did he release
anything new to the in EP and 2017 you
know say like he's not really some [ __ ]
like God I don't know if he just you get
like stuff so much money in the bank
like [ __ ] this your mind man yeah like
comics do that too I was like [ __ ]
movies when I try to come up with new
material or do you want a bus what
yeah right where do you want me to go a
bus which is what musicians do remember
I'm Radiohead right as big as it gets
and they were talking about how they
would not talk to each other they get on
a plane and they couldn't really even
look at each other I was like well they
weren't even well they're singing the
same song over and over again
and they're together all the time and
then they're on stage and after a while
you start to go crazy well with anyone
though if you put in a mini or any
before best friends for with each other
non-stop in a small confined area
perform on time anybody you didn't get
any [ __ ] nerves I need my space man
especially missed home it gets a little
weird how was your Halloween man you
dressed up as the I was a bridesmaid I
mean I was I handmade I was a handmade
did you post it on your I need to have
the video I made a video and I will I
should probably post it now so that you
guys can watch it but it was pretty
crazy I'm still reading text me post it
so Chinkin
put it on there oh I'm gonna do that
right now should I do that right now go
for it do it dude let me see which one I
want to do though well he's doing that
you can bring up mine I was The
Incredibles and apparently it's a
popular costume cuz every [ __ ] dude
with kids did the same thing I think Joe
Budden did it rob dyrdek did it okay
that outfit uh didn't need much padding
that's real I want you guys to know that
my dick was hanging out the front kind
of vulgar your Tong was yeah look at the
fat they got the front there
Oh menu that's all I love he's so cute
you're cute too though nothing about my
dick and then you're a friend of my son
we're down so cute yeah you see it there
dude just kind of [ __ ] hanging back
by the way your your girl it doesn't
need an Incredibles outfit because she's
built like a superhero naturally well
that thing has no that thing's just a
that yeah I've said to her before when
I've seen her walk and I go seriously
just shut down the street it'll shut
down something like I'm looking at I'm
walking behind her I don't job this is
ridiculous gym like fellas like get it
but it's ridiculous
put your tongues back in your head and
I'm talking about seeing her in sneakers
shouldn't have to wear high heels she'll
wear sneakers and stop traffic with that
booty smoke Joe when it comes to high
heels it's how to cut it down I keep her
ass indoors
yeah well keep that bitching goes now
did you pause the video no I just sent
it to chin oh it's me now that far right
do you think you're every bit of 67 at
the bottom look at that phase ii an
older bubble you get an older dude i
mean that's terrible your face changes
it's also the camera
it makes my nose look yeah come on ego
somebody i read the comments i'm that
somebody goes it somebody goes could
your nose be any bigger especially in
the morning give us huge nose you know
this we both have big painting do you
have a [ __ ] Schneider I haven't the
thing is we're getting older dude we're
both getting older yeah does yours you
know it's not a good thing when you get
older well gravity's really like yank
you know what yanking I'm the old
eyelets on me it is it's yanking on him
those are curtains dude
like I can't see my eyes meanwhile cats
get younger she gets older look at
Asians dude they don't [ __ ] around I
know that's depressing
I'm your face I'm not got a good chin de
that I'm you'd never guessed Chin's 40
something [ __ ] agents dude yeah
although you get old quick like
something happens we owe over
cinderello is written for Asians
it's like midnight hits and all of a
sudden they just go 0 to 100 you guys
turn into truck and post Tales from the
Crypt you know there's a big huh that's
why we waited for well alright well you
tried it's my video it's cool outfit
though dude
did people dig it um yes do you wanna
like that's so good
yeah it's good pretty simple too like
yeah red poncho and a bonnet is that up
on it
that's a habit we call that a habit I
think Monica literally Cape where I'm
from no I'm saying which what you're
wearing on your on your head
Oh more a visor you know most societies
with women have always tried to keep
them shielded they've always you know
they've always like patriarchal
societies and I like to believe that
someone in those societies look like my
girl and the guys are like let's cover
this [ __ ] up so it's like a novel that
would be the idea it's like guys can't
get anything done unless we cover women
in cloth making beds but now in this
modern in these modern times
I'll dude when I'm at the mall be with
my kid I'm like god damn these young
girls with their cutoff jean shorts are
like your ass hole is hanging out the
back of your pants yeah your ass hole is
out young lady yeah and as a now as a
man I'm like Jesus girl you know like
something caught my attention yeah but
but also inside I'm like you gotta put
your ass away you gotta put your ass
away I'm sorry is this is this yeah is
this sapphires is this the strip club
yeah no this is the mall [ __ ] right put
your ass cheeks away I don't if you
notice this you're gonna notice it when
your daughter daughter does it I'm not
like that as I get I was with Frank
Grillo and I and we this
beautiful woman stopped us - she was
selling stuff for Oxfam which is as
charity she was just gorgeous and Frank
and I were looking at her and we we just
kind of were nice and spoke to and as we
walked away he goes I never want to
flirt I go what I mean because I just
want to see him we're getting older I
don't wanna be the creepy guy
how old is I understand she was probably
like 22 so when you're 51 you can't you
can't what you do when you're younger is
put to get my face get something on it
do I believe you guys didn't look that
young lady you know your looker now up
and down but you got to do it in a
subtle manner like you have to say
things like I love you what do you want
pay your bills
what's the charity I'm telling ya but
you want to live yeah exactly
you want to drive my Tesla other than
that these young girls with their
[ __ ] jean shorts man well Harry my
daughter now at 10 weight as they get
older wait dude and now she's still just
a she's a 10 year old but I I walked
into the room the other day and she was
getting changed and she covered him her
boobies hello I was like hey hey and
that that's not gonna happen now all
right you're still a kid let's go then I
know he's already becoming like dude how
about my son is seizure-free since I
started CBD oil oh yeah dude that's
great it's a man he's sound like 1 or 2
like he was more on the mild spectrum of
things you know but some kids like I was
watching a thing on I mean at CNN or
telling where the [ __ ] it is but a new
drug came out which is CBD but it's FDA
approved but guess how much it is for
pants that's not covered under 35 grand
but it's like but you wouldn't know like
it let's say like my dad being older
gentlemen like if if let's say his his
wife had seizures and they're like hey
you need CBD oil he wouldn't know where
to get it
you're like alright just write me a
prescription I go pick it up but if you
know kind of your [ __ ] you can just
figure where did CBD oil at yeah so it's
from a legit place where you don't have
to go through a pharmaceutical or doc
yes well when I when I was having my
psoriasis issues with no longer I have
that here it is Garner
thank you Dan Garner Dan Garner 88 @g
if you want if you have psoriasis and
you want somebody can really help you
dan garner 88 at gmail whose friends a
PhD Andy gallopin amazing guy anyway
I I was I went to get a cream that my
dermatologist gave me was a steroid
cream now ask me Brendon how much a tube
without insurance how much a tube that
big cost how much and I'm talking about
to like you know that's you know where
I'm awesome yeah honey
she goes you have insurance I go now
I'll just pay for it she goes I don't
think you will
and I went how much this thing with my
son though they wanted to do like
there's medication you can give them you
know and for some kids you have it like
really really bad
you can go those medications what they
found that CBD oil does way more wonders
than these other prescribed medicines
it's way more healthy for you because
there's some crazy side effects with the
drugs they want to give kids crazy Sarge
or change the changes their moods or
personalities it can cause a bunch of
problems but since we strokes [ __ ]
fired up the CBD oil zero problem so far
well I guess cuz I probably talked about
this before but when you if you have a
really bad psoriasis instead of your
eyes changing your diet or change well I
mean right so so can be rheumatoid
arthritis whatever they're certain what
they're finding more and more is that it
has some probable your gut right that's
the newest science but forget all that
if you have a real problem they want to
give you certain drugs that do work a
lot of times you can't get life
insurance because they will increase
your risk of all kinds of weird diseases
so some medicines definitely work and
they're very important but back back to
this thing with my son so this drug that
they approve you know some kids have a
hundred seizures of the day hmm and and
sometimes the prescriptions that the
doctors give them they they can cut it
down to like maybe 80 a day but some CBD
oil and and some kids the medication
doesn't work at all but in CBD oil it's
cut allows kids from a hundred to one a
day to tell seriously so but this is CBD
oil is not psychoactive Li no act not it
also comes from the same plant
yeah but you know it's a completely
different strain it's completely thing
it's a different it's a it's a it's a
molecule that's not psychoactive yeah
it's not site so there's no there's no
psychedelics there's none
that with it there's no high with it
there's nothing but but it reduces
inflammation or was hand yeah it does
wonders man I've started since it helped
my son so much I started taking it
myself every day yeah he look at the
best sock man Wow
then and I think in some cases it can
shrink tumors yeah there's a lot of
crazy [ __ ] but all they know for real
reason with comes the epilepsy it's
[ __ ] crazy for the brain what he can
do for the brain right you can't huh
that FDA approved this but it's so
expensive for parents it's like that
[ __ ] you doing man how but that's huge
man if it goes from a hundred to one
yeah for a lot of same for a lot of
people but again there's some kids where
nothing's working
can't imagine sometimes they grow out of
it right some of them if they're benign
some don't
there's dip there's all different though
thing I'm one and there's all sorts of
different forms of epilepsy there's it's
I mean it's a misfiring of the neurons
yeah and they don't know it's a you know
starts as a child but there's there's
adults who have it you never got cured
it just depends if it's benign if it's
this type if there's a you know thirty
different types of seizures yeah from
epilepsy it's [ __ ] crazy your whole
body is one big complicated machine yeah
a little thing one thing go wrong I was
sitting next to a cancer researcher and
he said there's a molecule that can
decide to activate and it can cause and
it's like game over it's game over
it's like what game what molecule like
what do you mean I'm Molly what the [ __ ]
you talkin about hey my dog has what's
called meningitis congenital meningitis
right so and which was my Corgi so my
Corgi for a month wouldn't move and just
sitting like this my Corgi is insane and
took him to the vet they ran four
thousand dollars where the tests think I
have dog insurance by the way thank God
cost me nothing and they said your dog
gets meningitis they give him a one tiny
pill I give him one tiny pill twice a
day and he is back to 100% normal it's
so sometimes medication can be a [ __ ]
wonder drug I mean for sure
exactly
he's unbelievable unbelievable but it
was a pill that's so [ __ ] tiny my
propecia this morning mm-hmm have you
been dating you back on the propecia
yeah why you want to get back on it why
do you think my hair is this thick as
yours now what do you think made you
want to get back on it what was that I'm
just saying it's not like it's good have
you ever seen young pitchers of like
when we first are doing the podcast like
looking it's the first thing I know
spike got down like you're Brian's here
yeah [ __ ] right a lot of things
change okay dude no side effects we were
with your propecia though what do you
think how'd it go half said propecia bro
does it yeah Oh propecia or finasteride
give me a break I mean I have to I have
to hold it together with two wood
splints but other fact other than that
you're good to go and I'm good to go
dude are you excited for San Francisco
I'm really excited when's the last time
we did a full weekend together we did
Phoenix one night but when I doesn't
want to that [ __ ] party afterwards
I'll go eat some good food I think it
arts in town - yeah
Toscana I want to go to Cafe Tuscan I
think this is called at that Italian
restaurant we're into a long time ago
knock your dick in the dirt dude did you
go to the tanning restaurant where we
went upstairs yo sis boy and it's like
no wait when today it was ridiculous
yeah that place was [ __ ] good there
boys on it Yassine brothers have that
[ __ ] locked down I know they're not
going they got that town lockdown I get
into late tonight stuff to be pressed in
the morning all the early shows are sold
out and the other shows are almost sold
out like I'm killing do press yeah yeah
well hey it's Danny here cancel whatever
here we have San Francisco
Brendan crazy flight khabib Conor what
let's talk about it that was two months
ago I know but your thoughts on it well
I'm trying to sell comedy tickets so I
don't get one well there it is ladies
well various go Stephen Cobbs comedy
club there is a fight expert I'm like
dude why the [ __ ] my nose or they bring
me and they're like well I happen to be
Floyd mate with a breakdown for us two
things and they just stare at me only
two things I fights not happening how do
you know what if it did happen and then
at the end I'm like alright thank family
no problem go see him gobs comedy club
he's hilarious
and if by the way if you are on the
East Coast you'll wake up at 3 o'clock
a.m. your time and go on and do and feel
sick to your stomach take sick to your
whole buh-bye stop don't do those
anymore now it's the only diva move I do
I to see all you because I love cobbles
like out come and do at but other than
that I don't do anything you know when I
stopped doing it I stopped doing I think
when I was in spoken I you know I woke
up you know smoking is a weird market
for me the shows were good but they want
to be do press like you know problem and
again it was all like just they were
fight break down or football and like
house is selling comedy tickets like ask
me about some other [ __ ] man yeah what
are we gonna do yeah exactly
made gum like not doing anymore can't do
anymore man upset no I'm all good it's
it's such an old-school way of thinking
it's sold school you have to be in your
car at that exact time listen that exact
station like alright yeah oh he broke
down [ __ ] could be mayweather yeah
I'll go see him do some comedy right
it's very straight and then there's some
radio stations that are great and they
get it yeah and they know how to set you
some some do some have been around so
long that they have this loyal listeners
yeah so like John de Bella in
Philadelphia is amazing who's our boy in
Phoenix yeah the boys use grass I love
that guy is [ __ ] amazing using every
way yeah and then oh what the hell's are
called in Philadelphia oh my god I can't
believe I'm bringing out here to there's
uh what is it one oh thank and Kevin and
bean Kevin bean as much as right on it
they're great and we never have to do
press that you know although I might do
it for my special but Stephen Stephen
those guys though they wake up at
[ __ ] 3 a.m. every morning and it's a
tough gig near we are ninety five seven
the vibe thanks for tuning in we're
sitting here with Brandon Schwab Brandon
good to see you good to see you you
still been a fighter you understand yeah
that's fantastic branch and then this is
my favorite so what was Ronda like how
was that like what the [ __ ] are you
doing that your last fight didn't go
well tell about the fight six years ago
correct
well I'm here what all right man I mean
that world in him
that's right ladies and gentlemen in the
worst I know if we do this for another
ten years my nose will be too big to fit
in this room because apparently your
nose and your ears grow as you could all
I know you're gonna suck up all the
oxygen
I'm gonna have to kill you I'm gonna
have to get myself a young nose job or
something like yeah those job wouldn't
be bad dude we got to figure out
something about the eyes and the nose
the eyes are easy to fake nose can't
really [ __ ] with kids change your voice
I don't mind dude I didn't realize I saw
a picture when I was young before I
broke my nose on the Ultimate Fighter I
almost looked completely different you
too and then I had a nose job find a
young that a nose job like well that's
probably not like a Hollywood nose got
her nose was sharper my nose that broken
I noticed and then they you know they
had to fix it and then my [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's too young
nope that's too early it would be none
of those no none of those different no
no that that was that uh okay your dad's
a Broomfield event center after I know
that a guy y'all named jail Easter in 53
seconds dude I like you with shaved head
man you don't you don't like you don't
know killing it with this long here and
you know I see what you're doing it's
because my hair is crushing yours you
wanna shave mine no I stole yours don't
look so so you should probably just take
it off you wish you don't think it's in
the way and it takes a lot of time to
[ __ ] mousse it down if you have a
Mane like this why would you want ask a
question just take it down no I broke my
nose there that's that's right after I
broke my jaw literally two days after
Anna you a young kid there yes just
shave it off there you go right there
go over to the hybrid over there with
the tattoos the skinny hybrid right
there
no which will hit one more one more over
here no go to the right there we go
right nope in the middle get off what
the [ __ ] bro
mmm all tatted up and big [ __ ] how reg
that might have been on I don't
recognize you I don't recognize that guy
that's a crazy picture your ears normal
it's not even that Kali know that my is
the exact same no yeah that's a man that
I respect up that's it that's my rider
dancer yeah that's this one
young bread and different nose bro would
you weigh their had a nose job by 2:38
there yeah you look pretty skinny skinny
kid kind of big bully boy and long arms
yeah you need a nose job dude click on
that one with me and Brian on
ridiculousness
check out the hair I'm Brian they're not
great oh thank you thanks for dressing
up for MTV get the wrinkly shirt on
you're calling your collar dude that's
depressing I'm depressed now I mean it's
like it's like I'm a guy from you know
it's like hey aren't you bro know this
you're supposed to be on the political
show with the guys over there you have
to sit on the roundtable with the old
old people getting older bro I don't
like it I'm gonna fight it
getting older man that's a good shot
good times yeah you can see it yeah
these your shoes are laced up super
tight you know just a right those are
great
those aren't grades are there all those
are the ones they're a little stiff you
got your suede no I'm Chelsea boot sir
nope those are shiny oh those are those
stupid the paint on expensive paint
splashers nicely thunk oh she goes to
climb buildings I see them you always
wear shitty clothes like that's your
thing but those shoes are the worst you
have ever worn
that's any of those socks yeah these
shoes are get there these are put on kid
bog and they're comfortable and they're
100% leather so kiss my ass whoa no
welcome to 2018 most shoes are leather
yeah these are so special and why are
the laces taken out because it's just
the style the kids are wearing nowadays
cuz I can't be hemmed in my style that's
a good shot right there that's dad
that's where it's like Bryan Callen a
good-looking guy I mean come on see that
was like that was like teetering like
right and then I went boom like right
there look at look at us some dime
pieces there guys especially in black
like you know like I got two blue you're
just blue but whatever I'm wearing
yeah you're in blue double blue and I'm
in double black does the guys Choice
Awards
we saw Kendrick Lamar wait there's the
UN who's that guy I know what that's the
greatest rap on earth you went that
little thing with that little thing he's
a small man then Joe Pesci and Robert De
Niro came out there Joe Pesci's fool
crazy now yeah yeah that's true and then
there was DeNiro
um I I like that picture that's a very
good picture of us a couple cutie pies
right there shank at what he has that
going on this weekend let's get off
reminiscing about the old days when me
and Brian were much better looking in
poor nothing much just working that's
all you do his work yeah except for
yesterday I was gonna go out with my
friends but my dad came into town for a
business trip last-minute so cat in town
yes out here he's doing business
business quote quote unquote
did your sister listen to the last
podcast yes she did
many notes recommendations you're a
smidgen too light for her and by a
smidgen oh my god yeah
I can't an a smidgen too late um don't
do blackface though no I get to a
certain point when you tan loan too much
really I can't
I've been tanning forever um was it oh
you guys [ __ ] up yesterday cuz chin
and cap take a picture together
and chin introduced the world to cat and
tagged her profile as soon as I saw that
went well cats gonna get a lot yeah had
happened eventual do you actually get
dick pics from guys yeah I recently got
two of the pinkest dicks I've ever seen
in my life
like they are like rubbed out yeah we're
like pink and sad they send you a
picture of them was it straight up it's
got a dick big look it looked like it
was but I mean I so you always as a
woman when you get when you get that
you're gonna expect to get at least a
couple of weird yeah for some reason
only white dude send dick unsolicited
dick this though well now you said that
you can get a bunch of black well you
don't hear a asian guys sending dick
pics really yeah no well well what
Brendan
hey you know saying I would you know
hate to make assumption you'd assume
black guy said I knew you were gonna get
them cat because I've never tweeted out
or blast out your IG for that reason I
was trying to protect you from the
onslaught of dicks see dick pics aren't
attractive but what what is attracting
is like the gray sweatpants like with
you guys like the dick play but not the
dick pic you know on the same way with
ladies the print yeah I don't like the
full-blown like get your [ __ ] on my
face I like like in a thong like a thong
and you know I'm saying be like leave
leave my let my imagination do some work
and that'll lead you to [ __ ] put up
the whole [ __ ] enchilada I go home
for you how is that the the Westside
Brewing Company back in the day was a
comedy thing we'd all do everybody would
it's in Westwood okay and so I there is
a girl there and she was she saw my act
and she was putting the full-court press
on me and she was with comic I camera
and she dug me and so I I gave her my
number and stuff and we start talking or
whatever and she I we started talking
and she said I said I was something I
said if we bored she sent me a picture
of herself and I said love sexy pictures
if you're bored feel free to send away
you know just put yeah I just thank you
yeah I am NOT every means mileage I'm
not exaggerating I get this I'm really
like so at first it was like this
picture of her life you know that's what
I could see kind of like just her
cleavage I was like Jesus just like your
pull top yeah like a shoulder I am NOT
[ __ ] kidding the next picture and I'm
gonna do it for you the next picture and
that was this and I'm not right I'm
really not joking
watch this oh oh and I didn't know how
to respond so I was like what do I do
here this person is crazy and I got then
nice I got too much I know I yeah yeah
no no no no it's fantastic on you I find
out she's a porn star and yeah and then
ice
saw her I didn't see her I saw her at
the Bruin come in the next the next time
yeah and she smelled she smelled so
strong and bad
Bjork I don't know what it was it was
bad smell it smelled unhealthy and and
then I saw a thing where it said and I
looked her up I looked her up I want to
see you know I looked with I know Lord
and said such-and-such smells like ass
so even the guys that work for the
nurses I was like well this is none of
it is good none of this is good you're a
disaster so aggressing you oh you're a
great you sent me a picture of your
[ __ ] Oh
as you're peeling your other parts off
God and you smell like ass there's
something makes you feel em wrong it
makes you feel doing poorly
it's all wrong it's all wrong what's
like the comedy it's like the it's like
the guy word you know whatever slides in
the girls damn and then she's like hi
and he's like it's not an invitation for
a giant dick bag read the read the room
know the room yeah we're all swimming
we're all waiting in the pond we don't
need you to cannonball it's nothing
worse than a girl does that you got hey
I'm doing [ __ ] like I don't like strip
clubs I'm not a big strip club guy
anyways but anyway but I don't like it
when it's full nude now I like underwear
on top now I don't mean like granny
panties but like a thong sexy is sexy to
me
yes I don't need the full blown like
meet your [ __ ] my face on these
[ __ ] out chicken wings you don't say
oh yeah you did your shirt on
yeah I'll have roast beef there yeah
primary wholesome of me and my [ __ ]
oh my face like goddamn it man I know
you'll see guys so I can slap you in the
[ __ ] head with a dick I don't need
any of that
close-up [ __ ] me neither man I'm even
porn oh my god dammit it'll [ __ ] the
whole vibe up we have a nice time
jacking off alone
then he'd been if they go too much and I
have you ever gone through like if
you're looking at porn you're gonna do
porn hub or whatever and then did
there's that there's a [ __ ] you're
like did it and now sudden you just see
kick with it yeah well I with a guy with
ten
and a giant dick no in another kitten
and Uzi liked it it's like dealing best
titties another site it's like well
that's in it I got a look that's
impossibly giant got a gift for a meme
where there you see the repair and I'm
like why is it doing that
you're fine what sometimes my that might
have recommend fat chicks like what the
[ __ ] oh my god why is it so fast
oh oh dude granny's that like the fun
nope nope I'm with you sometimes they
say recommend one and it's just this
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's pretty face huge
tits
yeah and just this [ __ ] machete for a
tip but you got a giant butt holding it
like it's a [ __ ] trophy fish yeah
like this yeah trou banging another cow
with a dick dude it's weird apparently a
lot of guys look at this this is what I
want to say make up your mind but also
how did you get such a giant dick well
you know because they they have a woman
trapped inside of them and just heavy
machinery that they have to work around
what and then their bubble but sometimes
it's confuse it's confusing my brains
like like short circuits like I know
what are we doing let's remove that or
do I click on it it's 13 minutes long I
mean that's what's going on have a 30
minute window I could I could have a 15
minutes take a nap right I'm gonna watch
it I'm gonna think about yeah I gotta
check it out that's right
maybe I'll sometimes I'm halfway through
before I even realize it's a chick with
a dick you know what you know how I
don't understand when guys i watch
animation porn what the [ __ ] they watch
cartoons [ __ ] get it now
you know what no I say that loud Chin's
that type of guy
shin watches that animation portion
where it's like it's like an octopus
with seven dicks four tentacles spots a
girl chin gets Botox and he watches that
so his face doesn't move Roseanne face
you know sassy used to dead to me right
so would I'd be on the road and I would
just get a picture out of nowhere
he'd have he'd drive by my house and
either they take a picture it I used to
have a house my house just have a little
window in in the front door and I just
get a picture of my the inside of my
house do that or or I would just I get a
picture of him holding my two kids in
each arm
pilatus it stop by he'd have a dead face
dude sometimes just send me a picture
delete or someone send me a picture and
if I'm like boarding on my flight and
I'm like what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] like I
have to put it down like what the [ __ ] I
got a picture like a nice taking that
lazy dick of mine I was in Utah on
Friday option knows it was it up or down
yeah herniating out of here yeah hold
your underwear down and they were in
there they were pushing your nutsack up
and tight and then you had this you did
was she kind of it was sitting like that
agree the sound effect for it is angry
and lazy yeah yeah look like your nose
you get that out of here get that out of
here man should you some current events
forget to dependents please for the love
of God let's do this
so footage came out of a daycare Fight
Club [ __ ] sakes man year-olds a
ten-year-old did this that's his little
brother crying after three fights one
teachers excited jumping up and down
while the other teacher puts focus on
Jesus Christ mother Nicole mercele
cannot watch without crying I would be
so [ __ ] angry yeah maybe if the if
those were male teachers they'd be tough
for me not to go in back you don't do
Fight Club
when the kids aren't in like Christine
Fight Club put those guns on we're gonna
fight for you guys don't wanna fight
either neither to my son so now you're
gonna fight and I'm gonna lock the door
I'm sure I'm gonna get arrested for this
but both of you are gonna fight each
other now and I'm gonna watch ya and
then I'm next
I'll fight the winner tagging and even
if you win you're next yeah give me two
of you I mean you're gonna start
throwing some bones and beating people
up if you do that to my son yes that's
that's gonna go down yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna get arrested
yeah I can do a lot of time but I have
some good stories I'm gonna get a bit
out of it it's worth it yes oh you're
helping me that's amazing
that's ridiculous man God what's wrong
with these [ __ ] teachers and the
police will not prosecute the the two
women who set it up why we're not sure
what where where's the set properly
because you can't show any like actual
harm so the kids aren't bruised and
beaten up but they're they're scared or
the war one kid didn't like it the other
kids were roughhousing and playing right
so when I came home the other day my son
my son's two friends were had my boxing
gloves on and they were going at it
these are six year olds going at it I
mean crazy I had to stop there zero
hitting each other and face and laughing
yeah they don't know cuz their date they
can't they're too weak to hurt each
other so they're just [ __ ] whale and
I said a wrestling and it looked brutal
but it you know so some so well the
problem is that the kids were crying
upsetting their sons I said hey make
them fight yeah that's the problem I son
sensitive these two kids are not my son
wouldn't be into it but those kids would
so it depends on the personality of the
kid if not what those two kids look
here's the problem even if your kids are
into it this isn't okay even if four
year-olds are into fighting each other
that's not okay at daycare in any facet
any form
why are those gloves there why you allow
these kids to fight you're getting paid
to protect these children said that they
should not they should not have work
she's married to having the kids fight
each other with the Hulk hands to
release stress so no that makes sense
yeah it's four-year-olds need to really
subside in much it didn't last for more
than four minutes and that none of the
kids were hurt I mean I understand I I
understand how you put on these hug
gloves and there are little kids and
they're playing around so I can
understand they're already being
roughhousing if it was a random thinking
brother like show-and-tell then two kids
start going at it it's possible those
women are not bad it's possible try one
cheering like that that's a little weird
I think they just they just don't
they're just as it might have been just
a dumb exactly when you're around those
little kids just having kids at that age
and I've seen it when you have kids like
that they start to roughhouse and they
do actually boys will play
I've seen it a thousand times I know but
listen I I get it my son's as rough as
they come yes
any teacher that's celebrating like that
can't be around my kid Oh Shi Wu ji yeah
you know that she actually thinks that
she's doing something good yeah this way
we saw he can't be a teacher
no five second clip so we have to be
careful a little bit there might be if
the if the the Circuit Attorney's Office
is not prosecuting my guess is there's
more to the story it looks a lot worse
now if you are gonna do that though I
understand the mom crying here's the
thing here's that here's the problem
it's 30 minutes of kids fighting she
said it was four minutes
no no videos no day care cameras
recorded more than thirty minutes of the
kids fighting yeah an older son texted
her saying that the daycare was make
making them fight the new station also
quoted police reports saying that the
two teachers were fired over the
incident so there must be something here
now they got fired and I said that st.
Louis attorney's office declined to
prosecute okay look yeah I mean I'd be
bummed out of my kid was crying here
here's one guy man defends hit dressing
five-year-old son as Hitler for
Halloween and he said we love history I
go in that and not get sucker-punched
that's incredible
incredibly dumb well so far so I have
another word for it incredibly racist
maybe right like yeah you he's enjoying
that a Kentucky man all right come on
who are Nazi costume dresses
five-year-old like Adolf Hitler is
defending the outfits wow dude the
daughter wore a fairy costume so that's
good the photos taken down on Thursday
yeah he's a racist
anyone who knows us knows that we love
history and often just the part of
historical figures okay what a [ __ ]
somehow I that's
real outfit and somehow I think he wears
that yeah that's just not yeah
something's going on there
I'm it's a yes it is hardcore man as oh
my god what a bad dad
ask murderer Jesus Christ man and that
symbol that symbol that was responsible
for I don't know 8 million deaths
probably not just Jews but gypsies gay
people you know people dress up as El
Chapo and Pablo Escobar too though I
suggest that that's it's different in
that Hitler all poor Texas yes but but
and I agree with you poor taste I
understand
El Chapo and stuff because really yeah
you know innocent people I think it's
terrible and I agree but i but i but i
somehow understand them as being sort of
characters in the news there's this
folklore around um you know with narcos
and stuff i can get it that dough with
that symbol you're wearing it you're
wearing a swastika sir that's pretty
wearing it well that's definitely works
not i don't prove any of it right I
wouldn't do I'll chop ax or Pablo
Escobar but I also wouldn't be that
offend if someone came is like I guess
what now now if you're from Guadalajara
if you're where my girls from and you
know the town's been terrorized by them
and you wear that be like what the [ __ ]
man yeah but but but that that right
there you know your your dressing your
San Jose as a guy who's responsible for
beginning a war starting I'm the one of
the most evil men of all time yeah and
racist but also that with the [ __ ]
symbol of not their swathers yeah you
there's no mistake and then and then
don't make the kid [ __ ] get them
crying just deserting just as you're
dressed I believe is Eva Braun no she's
a fairy okay close but very close Bryan
but that's unfair you know the Hitler
give me do you know two things about
Hitler I would surprise you in terms of
do you know how he ate he was a
vegetarian thank you do you also know
one other thing he was supposedly uh
drug addict nope
he was celibate he's a drug addict too
though I don't know he was said I never
read that he was celibate for sure drug
addict yeah really yeah yeah his doctor
came out with all the stuff they used to
give him
crazy amount of drugs it's elevate
though for sure didn't have sex probably
a very small genitals by the way so
upset yeah didn't get into the blitzed
Oh cocaine yes but I knew but opiates a
lot of opiates really yeah try to stay
awake yeah exactly
they said he'd work around the clock and
a lot of drugs and that time they didn't
know they were like that bad he just
took him and then the the Nazis also
took nothing yet so far a lot of times
and he would salute like this and they
would yeah it's probably a physician
that's what I read I read this book
around here like I don't know why people
we're into that [ __ ] well you should
read about the describes the Lord the
role of drugs and Hitler is interesting
to me what I most significant he's he's
one of the most significant figures in
in 20th century and in history and also
actually has to do with where we are
today in a lot of ways oh yeah
he'd also do a lot of hormone injections
really yeah is that right yep Wow was uh
germ all nine in 1941 with the first
opiate but especially with the first
hormone injections then in the forty
three the third fate starts with the
heavy opiate phase well if we could do
some drugs um crazy Hugh is a [ __ ] uh
vegetarian though right loved animal
well he was a big proponent of like the
Upanishads and and sort of the idea so
so so the Hindu scriptures and how they
wanted to organize society so so Plato's
Republic which was Plato's program the
most famous philosophical treatise was
sort of how you out the Plato's argument
for how to outline a society right
philosopher Kings at the top and you
everybody has a caste system and the
Hindu the Hindu released belief as has a
caste right so he wanted the Third Reich
which was the new Germany essentially
was going to mimic a caste system and
the Jews were the racial purity a racial
turn on top and ultimately he wanted to
create what the area was like the Aryan
race yeah the Aryan race and all the
other races that were brown what he
called the mongrel races of course with
the Jews all of them had no place and
had to be
exterminated ultimately so the final
solution they talked about was getting
rid of first the Jews and then
ultimately everybody he's gonna work his
way yeah Jews were just first but he had
enormous respect for the British Empire
and actually for Japan and tried to
create an access to power between them
and he thought the United States was
powerful but their their racial policy
didn't work and so he didn't he thought
they would implode
you [ __ ] up yeah he was a real a real
what's called an ideologue
hell she got Jin do you guys ever
watched better call Saul know if you
never had a channel it was on the same
one as bad team see that I think was AMC
so there's an actor this guy who's on
that show he's also in a movie called
the men who stare at goats with Clooney
okay and apparently this is on barstool
he cut his own hand off a while back and
posed as a wounded warrior to get these
jobs wholly took a skill saw cut off his
own hand in a psychotic he deserves it
oh my god how bad you want to be you
want to be Batman okay so I can hand off
that guy's crazy
holy [ __ ] but here's the problem he
acted like was he in the military no so
he lied about it but he's coming clean
now it's it's been on his conscious for
a while so he's letting everyone know he
doesn't care if he loses like future
actor zigs picture the holy [ __ ] he cut
his arm off to get roles in Hollywood Oh
his hand well it looks like dude how did
he do it skill saw do you know in a
psychotic episode yeah well there was
that one guy who cut his hand off and
sent the video to the FBI because they
had his brother in jail or they were
going after his brother and he he was
like he showed them how [ __ ] tough he
was and he cut his own hand off like
that you know that story no Senate the
FBI and said here [ __ ] come get
us
was that be like all right cool man
we're out of hands it's got your way
easier to identify to the point you
[ __ ] no hand damn he said just uh Wow
that is [ __ ] nuts The Stolen Valor
thing I agree can't be forgiven but you
gotta respect of dedicate just sounds
like he's got he he probably has major
episodic now yeah I would you cut off a
finger to be the next being the next
Pirates of the Caribbean like the next
five make like six hundred million
dollars you get a finger off each one I
would cut my pinkie off yeah I need my
thumb there's no mouth there's no roll
my thumb pinkie take it Batman
take it I'm smiling at you talking
millions bro you you get up Johnny
Depp's career but you're not me so
shitty with your money you know I don't
want to act like that I would put some I
would put up with some [ __ ] for the
amount of money he I paid I would wear
that [ __ ] eye I mean doing now be
what's that did he do it now yeah but I
love the people I work with I don't know
about film it's like what if you love
them time and you're making 30 at least
a [ __ ] movie yeah I would you would
30 a movie oh he makes more than I do
with the money Brennan like drink really
did why yeah what of course I don't act
like don't hate hates me don't go to
Europe and be fabulous I thought I would
wear scarves like knock the [ __ ] up I
get [ __ ] net neck tattoos cat so I
wonder if this guy if he were like damn
that's badass he did it for the craft or
if they might [ __ ] this dude well I've
never heard him so I know a lot of
movies they're gonna say [ __ ] him
because he he's impersonating someone
that's a war veteran I think yeah I
thinks it's not like he's been killing
it though is it
it's not like it's like what if they're
like Robert De Niro cut his finger off
dick I you'd like what the [ __ ] after
all these years but within it's like oh
yes I think you'd have to be a real
psycho to cut your own arm on you know
Brendan and then pretend you and I know
guys that are borderline this don't we
yeah you know I mean I know guys who are
a little bit
so you know what even without the arm
you just miss just hate to tell you it's
just because you have both arms isn't
the reason you're not been out he got a
lot of so when he cut it off
you're still not Ben Affleck now you're
even shittier
and now you're in even less roles
because you have one arm we can't cast
he did it for acceptance he did it
because you wanted I mean he knew he was
gonna get like these kinds of roles yeah
you would think someone do some research
like the cuz I let if if you're on that
best like the boys from black rifling
you've got the they'll find out man it's
very easy for them to figure it out I
asked him like three questions like oh
you're full of [ __ ] get out of here
I have another thing to say mm-hmm how
about this maybe he didn't cut his own
hand off maybe he lost it in another way
and that's a second story cuz cuz ever
no usually you'd pass out like before he
can get through that bone high I mean I
severed my hand with a skill song that's
what he's saying
the state of my mind was a psychotic
episode how about this how about this
probably not right there you're right
maybe it's some [ __ ] like he got his
hand stuck in the fridge or something
like that and it broke I was
dishonorable I'm killing my career by
doing this if anyone thinks this was for
personal identification that's not the
case what are we gonna do with Adam I'm
asking myself from the New Mexico
filming straight and gladly so just to
say what I've said while he hasn't
wasn't taking his medication but now
he's back on his meds and wants to tell
the truth I'm just I look at my eyes I
know they're hard to see anyway but look
at them I don't buy it either be not you
say that you'd be pretty tough to take
your hand sonically yeah unless well
unless you just like this look but then
you go to the hospital there's army
records of it how'd you do it well then
he probably just say that buzz saw well
if you're willing to lie about being a
veteran people check that out it's real
easy it's like you whenever I would say
that guy fought professionally and you
go he did where what's his name and then
you got you look it up right now on my
phone and I'm like no because and you're
like no no not because no my god well
you're also three same amount Matt best
can figure out those fake soldiers I can
figure out fake fighters what gym
yeah there's about three four questions
before they get on this weird road like
oh you're full of [ __ ] yes yes don't
entertain the actors I'm young now what
else yet chin let's say come out do we
want this guy in the podcast sure sure
I'd love to hear the story Wow go ahead
you guys could figure might you think I
would have them on air and ask him some
questions I'm sure he's a nice guy
I mean he's coming out queen yeah he's
sound hey I see crazy yeah he sounds
like a very nice guy who probably go
batty
it may have yeah I may have maybe a
little batty that's all I'm sure he's a
good guy and I'm sure he's complicated
like all humans I'm not ready to say now
my boy who we've had on the show who
works for Discovery Channel for Shark
Week who got his arm and leg bit off by
a [ __ ] shark might have something to
say yeah hey you know what by the way he
might have had a psychotic episode he
might have cut his arm off and then he
might have said something like I'm
[ __ ] for life and then he got
desperate and came up with an idea and
it worked so sometimes when you're
desperate and you're terrified and you
and you lie it's okay to like I'm not
judging the guy man I don't want to
judge the guy I don't know what it's
like I mean I want to be his friend but
yeah I don't give ID you know what I
just don't give a [ __ ]
that's a cool hand by the way it's a
pretty cool hand no homeboys our boys is
way cooler that's strong [ __ ] death
grip carbon fiber 1en the mechanical one
would you rather lose a pinky or a
pinkie toe Oh pinky toe easily did well
you need it for my hands bro Topher
bounce man that's the weird thing about
that close my parkour would suck that
would suck I'm not willing to give that
up
yeah pinky doesn't do too much I mean
grip would be a little bit of an issue
seeing that little pinky to hang onto
the bars Carrie and for boxing it with
it it'll be terrible um I saw this on
Johnny Knoxville's Instagram it's about
a squirrel Guinea's nuts caught in a
fence oh it's so terrible but check it
out
well here's a better video says you
think you're having a bad day damn
that's cross emphatic did that
oh how terrifying help them out well
just lift and push it up dude I think
it's much harder than that you could
just take the board and go like that -
thank you yeah yeah help them out
instead of film well they did try to
help now so they took a wooden stick and
pried it open but the first stick broke
so can you imagine like came back it
probably like slammed on it again and
they don't even say like for sure that
they freed the squirrel they say they
tried to help free the squirrel that's
got some fat-ass nut those are huge
that's that's what that's what your nuts
look like when you send me that dick
those were some fat that's goddamn just
slide them over like you would fight you
right no not just you through there I
would get like a leather glove or
something and then and do that like lift
them yeah
but it's hard to think at that moment
what how often that happens - not often
Jen not often one one in a million at
least what I got is he's right just
right like yeah yeah just trying to go
over the front to see you laying down
dammit
you know they catch baboons right you're
not a catch baboons so they'll take a
right look stop but they'll take that
put a treat into a bottle the baboon
reaches into the bottle grabs the tree
but now he tries to pull his hand out
but he's got a fist but he won't let us
go of the tree cuz he's too stupid and
greedy oh ho so he'll pull but now he's
stuck in the bottle knocking the ground
that's how they catch you they do that
they do that too but you can't get it
his hand out a few releases so baboons
won't release now it's a good example of
what happens it's a great metaphor it's
used often as a metaphor for greedy
people
let's Dylan pick here you're not willing
to let go Wow yeah that's how they catch
him what else yes they used to kill
wolves that Eskimo used to kill wolves
by they take a sharp blade and they
would put a piece of meat on it where
they put some blood on it and the wolf
would come over and lick it
Oh wolf would cut its own tongue and
keep licking and be like this is
delicious and keep licking I knew what
it knows tell me
to death Jesus Christ it's a horrible
way but it's it's well so be smarter
it's also the way they deal with wolves
well the other yeah it's like people up
well in the winter when they get when
they would starve they would come and
eat all your food all right this is in
China and this is the PLA
the People's Liberation Army Air Force
and this is a guy trying to throw a
grenade over a wall this is a training
thing right and he hit the wall live
grenade live grenade this is a training
exercise in this is a trainer had to
save him so I'll show you the clip here
let's go back over here so there's the
cadet you can't make it over to that
wall
check it out cuz you panicked is this
Korea China China they're camos gonna
have 150 guys yet oh [ __ ]
so they had to dive into the safety area
and then oh no it doesn't make that much
still it's still a training grenade but
it could kill within like 6 meters yeah
Wow
Robo let's learn how to throw I am first
of all beautiful yes if I'm doing hey
throw the center ball first throw the
tennis ball first so I could make sure
you're not a total spaz I'm not [ __ ]
his general whatever have I can't take
this rock throw it that way from me all
right here's a grenade on the Goldbergs
we have a lot of child actors and this
kid was 18 and he had to throw a
dodgeball and we had to shoot him doing
that and he had been a child actor his
whole life he didn't know how to throw a
ball I'm not kidding hey I went well
that's that's crazy but he just had
never learned nothing hard times yeah
yeah you just get so insulated in what
you do he never had to and never had to
learn yeah if you got recessed with
regular kids you're gonna learn yeah you
can go home Ted I gotta learn to throw a
[ __ ] ball yeah that's crazy
that guy's yeah the gate price shouldn't
be up Murray know what areas what else
get you alright this is pretty sad has
to do with Stephan Bonnar he's fine but
he was arrested for felony DUI
his mug shots tough to him he looks
freaky and this is
third DUI had no idea I like to see me
seems like everything yeah he's been
really nice where's this this Nevada
yeah reckless driving a free in Nevada
being charged with misdemeanors and then
he was freaking out though right yeah
seems hotter so much people had to like
get him hold him down if he had trauma
that's what I would say be head trauma
not have in any like any direction where
to put his energy so you need a [ __ ]
pretty look scared damn it that's tough
yeah good get off well [ __ ] yep all
right let's go to this one so today
there's gonna be around 200 or so Google
employees walking out because of uh
there's this report that came out in New
York Times about someone that used to
work at Google who created the Android
and there was a sexual misconduct
scandal and it was enough evidence if
the investigation showed enough evidence
that it was credible so he got the boot
in 2014 I think it was okay and then it
turns out the Google paid I'm ninety
million dollars severance package which
but he's a Android yeah okay so that
that's in itself was kept under wraps
actually the Cal was kept under wraps
didn't say anything and then since then
in the last two years forty eight people
in Google have been terminated for
sexual harassment okay thirteen of them
held senior management or higher
positions but none of them got a
severance package at all so they feel
like Google's protecting this one guy I
mean the one guy who created they have
[ __ ] and I mean who made them a ton of
money that's where the saying that like
such a huge company is such a big deal
that's why so many of their employees
want to like walk out to say why didn't
you treat him the same way by Felicia
has the other people that died Felicia
if you invent the [ __ ] Android phone
I mean but you know I'm saying he so the
the thing he got caught on was he made
someone suck his dick like an employee
lucky cause the thing the story is
coerced it is I don't know google gave
Rubin I reported 90 million exit pack
into him 14 phone and investigated
analogous that he had coerced another
employee to perform oral sex on end
investigators really found that
allegation be credibly mean coerced like
what does that
that's a good question on your knees and
suck like what were you
but he's freaking us yeah we've gotten
to the person's head I don't know what
that means
this stuff is all crazy so people and
these Google employees are some of them
are so [ __ ] like an overly
progressive huh
all really progressive yeah so so people
are upset that this guy found out that
they found out yeah ninety million
dollars that's it yeah package and they
and they think these other guys should
get something no they say they don't
think anyone should get if you're gonna
be caught convicted or whatever okay
then if yes investigation shows that you
did do it was credible then you should
probably not get it that's not the way
it works that's what this is that's not
the way business and keeping it hidden
like if you're gonna terminate someone's
contract and if the guy invented the
goddamn Android phone they owe him a
certain mount of money even if he is a
shitty person
if you don't met your work you gotta pay
him something right and when I whenever
I get I get it they say hey these at
these [ __ ] predators should get
nothing I get that but when the guy
invented the [ __ ] Android phone you
can't just like go your fire thanks get
out it's like a contract he's like well
no hold on who's your might unique you
get sued and have to pay that anyway
first of all yeah that guy seemed like
that's fine if I'm for a sment however
the work I did provide freeze made you
this much money and then I'm gonna go my
separate way but you owe me this these
are not criminal trials these things are
internal and they look at the things and
they decide the other yay or nay and
there's a lot of pressure to fire
somebody based on accusation now hold on
hold on 48 people have been a for the
company for sexual harassment to you
it's a huge guy you got a huge company
every company has a huge huge chain
that's a lot that's a lot but I was
talking about this before she's like
well what what is the harassment how can
you know for sure what type of
harassment was well like just do average
terminations of sexual harassment yeah
that's a hard thing that this is a new
environment too so there's a new
zero-tolerance policy right but the
thing is it is 4048 high is higher ties
like that prison that whitey bulger died
in there's been three deaths in a year
that be high they have a issue they have
a real issue that it's high if if it was
I'd say it's high if the environment was
so cent wasn't
sensitive right I think right now
anything goes and it's well let's say 48
let's say 48 hi and the next average is
20 yeah this well here's what I have to
say Google Google to me I I I got
nothing for them right now because when
they fired James Dan more and I read
that memo twice when he just he was
trying to help out in an internal memo
and show exactly the difference between
men and women to maybe explain why
there's a discrepancy between
programmers who are men and women and he
got fired for making creating an unsafe
work environment who I'm so against Dave
dad James damn or I'll give you the info
about it he was a brilliant programmer
and he internally tried to say there's a
disparity was on Rogen's yes yeah yeah
and I love the while you and he's a
smart guy and he was just all he did was
cite the credible science but that but I
want any guy here you beat I hear you
there's cases I'm just saying I wonder
what the average is like Google might
have a [ __ ] problem well with that
many men and five women you're gonna
have yeah you're like Nike like what's
Nikes what's Amazon's like these other
companies that are maybe equivalent the
employees like I wonder what let me see
if I can get that figure you don't say
let's say um how many places Google half
so so the one thing is that there are a
lot of cases that are filed right so so
can I give you an example my friend and
it got dismissed my friend was accused
and what happened was he had to stop
working for nine months while they went
through this whole internal
investigation okay
so the minute there's anything you get
you can get in trouble and when somebody
Gil be hurt I'm not I'm not saying you
that but what I'm saying is if 48 men
were fired for sexual harassment they're
you know and I'm sure yours are 48 or
all 48 just animals probably not but
there's probably an issue maybe how many
people work in Google
now I don't say this in children it's
not the worst 72,000 full time stuff
72,000 abit 40s but it would be in the
but it's all over the world I'll be in
the office gin by the way it could be
all over the world you know different
offices how many people working in
Google in office how many let me just do
this how many Google company employees
no cuz the company's gonna be I think
subcontractors you'd have to I'm
assuming that three subcontractors yeah
yeah you're gonna when you have a come
into that big you're gonna deal with all
kinds of [ __ ] they plug its to it every
day you have lawyers on full-time
there's all kinds of stuff that goes on
there are 70 mm you know what 48 out of
72 says hold on it says half of them are
at the headquarters so 35 so let's say
35,000 48 out of 35,000 I don't know the
odds is that I don't know I don't think
like what's like how many does not think
that many people you're sure it's just
like having guys on the football team
we're out of a hundred
dudes you gotta gonna get four or five
bad acts yeah
forty eight out of ten thousand is not a
lot yeah what you say even forty eight
people out of 10,000 that was just like
a blip but I wonder what the what is not
saying like what in in in other like
high like Amazon at 49 well what's Apple
I also think what's Apple those things
are those things are hidden so this is
this like a not so so part of this
because they're not trying it because
they're not criminal things what
happened to be very careful about making
them public because you can sue yeah so
what they do is just to love saying be
like I wonder how many are in Apple the
apples [ __ ] you sure a lot well apples
also an international company right but
I'm saying like the office I know that
my father who worked at Citibank which
was the biggest bank in the world for a
while or at least one of them yeah the
number of like when you actually look at
stats like from soso credit card fraud
back in the day or now if it's still do
they know that no matter what with
credit cards they issue at all the
credit cards no matter what there was a
number I think was two point two percent
of all credit cards go out there are
fraud to point to it like so to point to
a you know isn't it just [ __ ] yeah you
know that's yeah and it's always like
that do so there's a certain thing that
you know going in your lawyers will say
well you know that and by the way 48 of
72,000 is what 0.01% or something crazy
you're gonna get that no matter what and
then you get a bunch of these
progressives is yeah I'd be I'd be
fascinated to find out what how me or
know where they stack up I did to the
other equal companies cuz when I heard
40 I'm like Jesus Christ so it's like no
they have 45,000 employees when you work
at Google it seems a pretty safe place
there might be some issues but in
comparison to the rest of the world well
here's the thing though that thought
that Google guy who would ever grabbed
her titties sexual harassment he would
be that guy whether it's at Google Nike
her at the coffee store payless shoes
finish line like a Google prom it's a
man's exactly just did you know bigger
than I am a bad dude a bad apple
progress I don't think it's like chaos
hey well around the world is changing
the world I mean it's the purge of
sexual harassment going on right now
alright what else you got chin wait well
check this out hopefully someone sent us
all the sexual harassment numbers it's
gonna be hidden the reason why these
were exposed is because there was like a
baby someone on the dark web might have
that [ __ ] bro
so it looks like they're all around the
world Google offices all around the
world people were walking out but is
that forty eight out of all the world's
at just their office no no people were
doing the walk out so I know what I'm
saying the sexual harassment cases is
that just from one particular office or
is it all the employees around the world
because all the employees all over the
world I don't give a [ __ ] because you're
talking about how many employees also we
don't know like hit like I don't even
know if he did get that second that that
package I you know I'm again I bet he
did there are times and they're
explosive expose days a lot of times I
know too many people who've been the
subject of over the past of the New York
toy it's pretty well documented that guy
got that pay up well he said it was a
gross exaggeration so sometimes that
number is also tricky because because
that those numbers that they throw
around a very very tricky it depends on
what you mean by ninety
you know how you break it down and stuff
a lot of it's a lie hmm honestly
interesting what else she gets all right
well this is just a little thing from
yesterday that was cool that Reese's
Pieces candy converter so if you were in
New York City and you buy this candy
converter if you get like crappy candy
you just put it in the Machine and oh
spit out Reese's Peanut Butter because I
would I would put candy corn in there
can't acordes you walk in [ __ ] [ __ ] I
would put God a ton of stuff what else
I had a Babe Ruth and my daughter was
like I do my daughter goes I'm not
eating she liked it she didn't like Mars
bars or or baby Mars bars or some - Mars
bars are like the poor man's [ __ ]
Milky Way
there's no caramel yeah Butterfinger I
[ __ ] love that Ricci piece he's
[ __ ] shoutout to Reese's we put on
that you know what say they do
um recently buttercups maybe but not
just in New York let's put that
everywhere
my son CPC so bougie he liked the
[ __ ] UH ones you get they're made out
of almond butter
what's the ones he sees butter cops no
no no he likes he sees one oh yeah the
buttercups but he likes the was it like
Jacob's the counties are from Denver
make no Justin Justin's he likes
Justin's dark chocolate almond butter
cups yeah what else you got chin
shout-out to Reese's oh this is not a
big deal but Christian Kylie Jenner
bought her mom Kris Jenner a $250,000
Ferrari for her birthday just for the
[ __ ] of it just right where her birthday
she makes so much money that's like me
buying Brian a [ __ ] Baby Ruth does
she got all right let's go over here
this thing oh my soldier dude I've been
deep into this have you seen this I
didn't see who it was
oh go ahead go ahead Jim all right so
you know who Whitey Bulger is he's a guy
that even these the reason why David
like Dana White says he left Boston
because of this guy this crime bomb
but yeah come hey so he was a mob dude
mob that was absolutely terrible
when Hill Gang do you know more about
this Brennan he ran he was chilling
winter Winter Hill Gang off see who's
murdered in prison he's murdered by a
guy who's from another mafia but he's
known for he's in prison because his
friends snitched on him so this guy
[ __ ] hate snitches so when they found
when him and his boys found out whitey
Bulger's getting transferred in which is
suspect well they paid a visit to his
cell and do you know how he died Bryan
well they put batteries in socks and
bashed his brains in law hasn't heard
lots and then tried to gouge his eyes
out and cut off his tongue cuz snitches
get stitches Wow
and you know what you see whitey bulger
deserves there's 89 years old and they
got him fine they said they beat him so
bad he's unrecognizable yeah they
couldn't they they're like and what's
crazy is you see in the in the tape two
guys walk in beat the [ __ ] amp come out
covered in blood come back in with a mop
because there's so much blood they're
trying to clean it up
like soak it all up so so so basically
he was because he was a snitch they
killed him ya know but here's the thing
about Whitey Bulger a lot of people
don't realize is sure Hollywood's made
him this fantasy and this badass stuff
like this he's the worst of the worst
when it comes to being a mafia guy
because what's the one thing in life you
don't snitch on people he's the ultimate
snitch and why because he's the FBI
informant so the only reason he got big
is he was an FBI informant so they go i
if you it will give you tips on what's
going on but you got to give up
everybody else which is what how he made
a career yeah and it's also how he
killed people apparently because they
owe to him who who was telling on him
correct and did you know he was also a
pedophile did you also know that he
killed women innocent women did you know
he killed an innocent man who's a father
he just ran by and shot because the guy
is with was they thought knew something
he didn't like him so they killed this
innocent man terrible person and one
gets glorified and memories and stuff
like that a piece and I liked watch all
the [ __ ] about him but are you talking
about a real piece of [ __ ] black
cycle valve you I love black mass in one
of my favorite movies but he's a bad bad
guy oh you're talking about a bad and
yeah yeah there's there's certain stuff
with young young girls 14 15 years old
I'm sure the guy like that there's no
there's no barrier Oh bad dude but the
guy who killed him Freddie Freddie oz so
him and his brother used to work for
another mob dude and they're not that
mob dude he was a hit man for that mob
dude and then that mob do turned on him
and that's why he's any they they were
gonna give him at least like a linear
sentence or leniency on sentence he's
like nope I don't do that I don't talk
so he stayed and that's why he has so
much aggression towards that why do you
do and the reason he's in is cuz they
flipped on him so when you know again
for mafia guys who are in the business
whitey Bulger's not looked kindly like
no one's admire what he's done
everyone's like that guy's the biggest
[ __ ] in the world
talking about he made a deal with the
FBI the feds to get where he's at
[ __ ] this dude and then snitched on
everybody so that's why when he got
caught when he's getting indicted all
his guys literally all his guys turned
on him they gave the whole [ __ ]
low-down then he was on the run you know
they caught him in 2011 in Santa Monica
right we're over there all the time
right there you know how he got caught
so he was gone forever and they were
like trying to figure out and there's a
here's that I think a hundred thousand
dollar reward something like that they
couldn't figure it out so they might
let's go after his girl so his girl
would get her teeth cleaned all the time
and get her nails done every week every
week so they got the FBI get smart and
put out all these things on his wife or
if you see this woman let us know and
she they caught her first and then
caught him and then what else is crazy
is with her is she so gangster they went
hey we'll give you a short sentence if
you got if you let us know who Whitey
Bulger was dealing with did the last
this long like give us the other names
and she wouldn't turn she no snitch she
was in a snitch he even even with that
she's a badass she's 67 right now she's
been in jail for the past seven years
for harboring a fugitive
this guy is interesting though handsome
guy looks good for 51 my age looks way
better than I do
he's not 51 there okay that's not a
current mug shot that's that's my
problem yeah
do we have a current mugshot of this
[ __ ] right now whitey bulger 89
is out him and Asami decided to [ __ ]
gouge his eyes and cut his tongue off
it's a bad way to go let's see him I
like him with his glasses let me get
something that this guy was the hit man
for the Mafia so he's already doing a
life sentence so what the [ __ ] does he
care
this man wait 38 years for revenge Jesus
Christ no let's see that at that picture
I clicked on it but it's gonna take some
time
well you could see him here right so
choirboy man bad guy mmm why'd he Bulger
though man he still was young he was
getting transferred all around - he's
getting transferred in the last place
cuz they said he's so charming with the
lady who was like his therapist he
charmed her so much he charmed her into
getting notes from his wife and once
they found that like oh we can't have
this so they sent them off crazy piece
of [ __ ] man yeah and they also the heels
like the families or whatever 38 million
dollars in you know you know in fees
which he's you know they can't find the
money so they sold a bunch of his [ __ ]
like auctioned off like his sunglasses
has changed jewelry pretty crazy though
man
sugar Winter Hill Gang yep
but yeah it's weird because you know in
that movie Jack Nicholson plays them and
departed yeah where you know you're like
damn skies a badass or when Johnny Depp
has you know yes they don't play they
don't let you know about that how big of
a scumbag yes like I'll see you kill
people so the people fantasize about
those mafias in the movie when you look
into like the what the [ __ ] he did with
like little kids and [ __ ] women like
oh [ __ ] yeah real surreal a sociopath
that's right
human beings are objects and if they're
in the way they're in the way and they
sent a lot a lot for him change when his
son died his son got sick and died and
they said that and his mom died the
following year they said it just got he
was like about John Gotti said he was
normal before that like mighty normal
like just doing normal mafia [ __ ] but
then once his son died and then once
mom died they said that he just went
full like yeah it's a little bit like
saying when he gets drunk he's an
[ __ ]
no he's just then you're an [ __ ] you
know when I get drunk I'm really nice
yeah meet this how are you yeah yeah
what else you got gin I heard that he
also um I've got two women are either
someone that worked with him and he was
afraid that the tumour we're gonna tell
on him it was like a mother and a
daughter he beat him up and then pulled
their teeth out killed him pulled her
teeth up killed them too you'd always
pull this out
he's a good guy all right so this is
Lucy key I guess he was protested at the
Comedy Cellar by some women fantastic
but how'd the show go inside should I'm
at the sold-out show in the the [ __ ]
standing applause that I feel weird
about this too like if you don't like
him just don't go to the show you know I
don't know how to try to do I guess I
mean what what is exactly what what
exactly do they want though my question
is do you want him to never do stand-up
again
what do you want to do or do you want
him to wait another year wouldn't I yeah
what what punishment fits that crime is
it losing his development they'll deal
with FX is it losing millions and
millions of dollars for his animation
for asking is it is it losing millions
of dollars for it because he couldn't
tour last year like what's it good
enough discipline for you is because if
30 to 40 million dollars and a penalty
fee is good enough for you that I think
he's done that and also remember what he
did we're talking 20 years ago be you
say this isn't current you're talking
[ __ ] that was forever ago and he was
yeah I did have a problem I'm different
I've changed now children what have you
done to do better so that happening is
well I haven't done this in 20 years so
also it doesn't matter
did they don't nobody believes in change
nobody believes that's my whole point of
when you did something like okay so can
I give you an example of me back I
remember when I was 23 I was arguing
with a woman about she thought that gay
people should be allowed to adopt
children I was ignorant
I said no so I was 23 21 I was like I
don't think that's right because I I
done I didn't know it was like so new to
me I was like what and then gay marriage
on if you had asked me when I was 22 I
would have said now it's for a man and a
woman I would have had my book I was kid
an idea then I got older and I got more
educated and I met gay people and I
thought about it and I had people give
me strong arguments before and now I
would say to you
of course I think gay people should have
adopt children because I know gay people
that have adopted children their
children are doing great
of course gay people should be able to
be married because I am older and I've
become more educated at the same guy you
were I wasn't ignorant I was an ignorant
young man and we're all ignorant at one
point that's why education changes you
so so Bryan Callen was a different guy
when he was 22 in a lot of different
ways than he is now but nobody's
interested in that change nobody's
interested in that well you did then
means that's who you are now and you
should be punished for life and that's
my problem with the left I don't know
what they want what are you guys exactly
looking for how much soccer is there any
sorry that helps you know what I mean we
have a system of law if you rape
somebody if you kill somebody you go to
jail you do the time we know what that
justice system is this kind of public
shaming I'm not sure where the
persuasion comes in versus the
punishment comes in but here's the thing
here's the thing these protesters the
loudest ones that's not the audience who
are paying for tickets correct that they
have nothing better to do they think
their calling is doing this they
probably live in in all honesty he's
even with well most people don't give a
[ __ ] you and I were with the people on
the internet who are up in up in arms
all this stuff weird cuz if Louie did a
theater show right now it would sell out
when I were with two big club owners
they down lots of clubs yeah and both of
them were like they had their finger on
the pulse they were like louis c.k right
now could sell out any theater he wanted
any big theater anywhere are you doing
entire tour around American setup
because though these the Liao's America
doesn't give the loudest ones barking
you know a lot of people like Louie lost
40 million dollars hold on
and he did this how long ago yeah I know
yeah he's a [ __ ] man yeah he's paid his
dues but then these women they're not
gonna be happy until he's what dead
broke but that they want total
destruction but they're not [ __ ] like
this she's like if you're Louie like
yeah all right I get it
you have fun with that I don't
I don't know you want me to do I said
sorry around the country are you gonna
follow me around and listen I'm we said
a sold-out show next month in Missouri I
don't know what you hear yeah that's
what else get you that should be it man
all right dude it's good stuff we talked
about important stuff we did dude we did
bro word you and I are gonna be in San
Francisco man I want to say thank you
for doing it it's gonna be fun dude I
can't wait it's gonna be fun the early
shows are sold out late shows are almost
sold out some tickets tea fat K calm
Friday Saturday night only Brian and
myself will be at Cobbs comedy club this
Friday and Saturday and then in two
weeks I'm in Sacramento
go and bring those dates up for me chin
like always you're sending dick pics I
will be in Sacramento at the punchline
Bryan we've done that together both yes
yes we have punch line and that is in
two weeks punchlines sacker man oh that
is November 16th and 17th then after
that I'm in New York City well my
favorite clubs ever New York City Gotham
comedy club that is November 30th
through December 1st then after that New
Mexico December 7th through the 8th and
then the grand old ha go so San Diego
January 19th Spreckels theater my
one-hour comedy special for Showtime in
San Diego can't wait one night two shows
only my friends are gonna be there
perform a couple friends couple friends
bro be cool man T fat K calm for tickets
that's it man I will see San Francisco
this Friday Saturday with Brian and
myself we have some fun we'll be around
excuse around San Fran say what's up I'm
excited being short shorts and our dicks
out in the front this is a fine kid
we're out